so if you were to come back physically
to that joke do you mind showing me the
move on my body Oh like for free yeah
okay
hey I'm Hannah I'm here fresh off
another battle with pro wrestler Dolph
Ziggler Dolph how are you feeling
relieved I got through one I was out
there with a killer Sarah Tiana
she got me good a couple times yeah I
watched it but you have heard good too
well I just wanted hear you say I just
said so I feel like I got a medal I
almost feel like an athlete that doesn't
exercise any beat athlete technically
yes Entertainment even though it's not
real so as a wrestler as a body slam
hurt more or when Sarah roasted you for
never winning about but I know you're
never gonna kill yourself because if
there's one thing you don't have in your
house it's a belt the ironic part is I'm
the current Intercontinental Champion so
it didn't really add up but it was such
a great joke it floored me pretty great
it was such a good joke I was just
really impressed I was so proud of him
amazing job yeah I almost thought you
helped him write the joke I did by
living my life she had one joke that you
wish you had said that you didn't get
out yeah he'd make a great boyfriend
because he doesn't care if you fake an
orgasm as long as you don't call it fake
entertainment a lot of people get
Brendon Walsh confused with Brandon
Wolf's from nine oh two one oh here's
how to tell them apart Brandon Walsh is
the funny one who's been on TV man I
feel great I just lost a roast battle
fight on Twitter
Barry's not funny and then started my
campaign I guess oh I did I started a
change.org campaign to get Todd Barry to
quit comedy I don't think he raised any
money
I wish he did cuz I would go off Twitter
for the right amount of money what's
your number a million dollars maybe okay
well that's a lot I follow your be funds
weather bureau yeah you also have way
more followers so did you feel like you
were coming to this punching down that's
the perfect way to describe roasting the
Brendon Walsh's punching em way down
hey this is tired baby I suck at comedy
I'm not funny hey thank you no that's an
insult can you do an impression of
Brennan crying Brendon crying yes no I
can't do this is there something you
wish you'd come back with sassy no it's
pretty happy with my comebacks several
people have commented on my Ron Howard
comeback
you look like Ron Howard if he directed
snuff films just wondering why he would
look different based on the filmmaker
moment of redemption you feel like you
wish you had said that the final joke I
was gonna do is Todd recently got a cat
so there will be something to eat his
corpse when he dies alone in his
apartment it's a good joke I didn't get
to do it on TV well the good thing is
most people don't have cable if they do
have internet so that will go oh
thank God
[Music]
[Applause]